we're dealing with new numbers that are
really cool i hope you're starting to
get a feel for how they work and if
they feel more comfortable and you're
getting used to writing eyes everywhere
and watching for your double negatives
all the rest
one of the things i want you to remember
is that every time you have learned
about a new set of numbers right when we
move from just doing
whole number maths to then working with
uh fractions and decimals and
percentages right
then when we introduced the weirdo like
irrational
numbers right every time we progressed
to a new stage
we had to say hey be careful right these
these new numbers don't behave
like the old numbers you're used to and
you can jot this down right there are
from very simple examples of this
we know that if you have something like
a half
times a third right this obeys
like you know the kinds of things you
would expect multiplication of just
whole numbers handles right you'd be
like oh i just multiply the top
and then i multiply the bottom
everything's happy right we were really
like this is nice
but then think back to year 7u or maybe
e5 or 6u
right we then said hey but watch out
because you can't just say
the same laws apply because you know
just multiplying the numerators just
multiplying the denominators
does not mean that you can just add the
numerators
and add the denominators right you're
like hey watch out these things aren't
the same
uh similar deal with sir so square root
of a times the square root of
b what's that equal to square root of a
b right and we're like that's fine
but in a very similar way to this right
you can't just add these things if you
had
the sum of two thirds you can't
you famously cannot combine them they're
like really anti-social right so it's
like
you can't say i'm just gonna have an a
plus b underneath the radical sign
that's what we call it
so you can't do these things you must be
cautious okay
we encounter similar issues when we move
into this
sphere this realm of complex numbers for
example let's just have a look
at this guy here and what i'm going to
do is i'm just going to set you a
question a challenge to try and work out
what on earth is about to happen
we generally agree that a and b can be
pretty much anything right
two and three or five and nine or
whatever you want right
but now we're encountering this whole
world of saying oh i have i can have
negative numbers
under my square roots now right it's
like a whole new toolbox that i can play
with so
so what if write this down with me right
what if
a and b were both negative numbers and
just to keep things simple let's let's
just call them negative one that's the
simplest negative number
we know how to work with right what's
going to happen
on the left-hand side right you get the
square root of negative 1 times the
square root of negative
1. we have a name for this now we're
like oh cool
this is i right so i squared
by definition what's that equal to
negative 1 right that's
by definition no surprises here right
the square root of negative 1 is that
number that if you multiply it
by itself you should end up with
negative 1. so far so good
now let's see what happens on the right
hand side
i've got the square root of a b
a b a
b yeah just check to make sure i haven't
like
you know pulled the wool over your eyes
that's the square root of a b
isn't it well last i checked last i
checked
negative one times negative one is one
square root of one that's the number
that if i multiply it by itself gives me
one is isn't that one
supposed to be right so
what what's happening here right
something has gone
awry and here's my first challenge to
you right
we're quite happy to accept this but i
wonder if any of you
like think back to when you first
learned this you guys are good enough at
maths you probably just said
sure and then just did the 50 questions
in the exercise and probably got them
all right
but why is this true like why do you
accept that this
is the case because clearly it's now
leading us
to some major problems so i'm going to
leave that as my first
watch the next episode okay